we notice that as well in terms of just
people getting films off the ground that
it seems like people are setting really
high goals not having audience in place
and then it's not succeeding yeah what
do you think are some of the problems
that we're going to be seeing going
forward I think the novelty right a
fixer her husband home and now
everybody's donated up with these five
times to someone maybe they've topped
out maybe they can see things go through
yeah so what do you think there needs to
be a an accountability resource for
kickstarter there needs to be somebody
who says I looked into their business
plan they've showed me their market
research they've told me where their
financing could come from if the
kickstarter financing runs out and so
there needs to be somebody who can do
that and then can say you know I approve
of this Kickstarter project they've done
their homework here's a badge you can
pin on that texture compression
they need to do to keep their site as
popular as it has been you know one of
the reasons why Kickstarter has a clip
SIA the crowdfunding sites is because it
had a really high success rate of that
success rate is jeopardized by products
that don't follow through making people
more hesitant to donate then that's
going to hurt them yeah and there's
their simple even just interface things
that they could do like calculate the
cost of shipping on this item you know
calculate the cost of packaging on this
item and calculate any sales tax on this
item stuff like that i mean i don't know
sales tax applies in most cases on
kickstarter but in general it's like
there are little things that people
don't think about that Kickstarter could
be more active in helping people to
understand they need you know to meet
their home it did a section called that
says what are your risks involved in
making that stuff about Lee yeah
new risk assessment section on owners
that you have to answer in order to put
up a Kickstarter but yeah I mean I think
it's it's not you know enough now just
to say I have a film
to be interesting something that I think
a lot of people still don't realize is
that it's not your friends and your
family that is making your Kickstarter
succeed it is the general public and
appealing to the general public and
bringing something new to
table which is why it's very hard for a
music video or a novel to get the type
of funding that
unless you know it has a name behind it
or there's like a really cool concept
behind it because you know one of the
most popular things on Kickstarter you
know has been you know iphone and ipad
accessories and there's only so many of
those that you can have four people are
like this is not that interesting this
is like the same thing over and over
again so I think you're going to have to
see people making you know stronger
gravity strategies in order to make
their campaign succeed the same time
part of that you'll see higher profile
projects showing up my
and just it's producing a film that just
finished its Kickstarter it's called
such good people is a like a queer
cinema feature and it has a number of
name actors in it and you know having
those names on board legitimizes the
sillim in a way that I'm making my first
feature i haven't done
Lord doesn't and I think that that game
is going to start to skew towards people
who unfortunately already have more
resources unless they are bringing like
unique concept
you